peu
[Musique]
le 21 décembre 1911 au matin à paris il
pleut il fait froid
une voiture automobile s'est engagé dans
le boulevard ornano c'est une delaunay
belleville ce qu'on appelle alors une
limousine la caisse et vert sombre d'une
voiture de très belle allure mais cette
caisse faire sombrer semé de taches
debout comme si cette voiture avait
roulé dans des chemins de terre il est 8
heures 20 du matin
et voilà que la voiture tourne dans la
rue ordener et à l'angle de la rue
ordener le chauffeur entend un bruit
suspect dans le capot dans le moteur il
s'arrête alors qu'y at-il dans cette
voiture à l'avant il y a le chauffeur
justement volant il s'appelle jules
bonnot à côté de jules bonnot jules
bonnot est un homme de petite taille
courteau avec mince moustache rousse à
nez en trompette et à côté de jules
bonnot il y à octave garnier un homme
jeune d'ailleurs benoît le plus âgé
vonau à 35 ans les autres ont tous entre
20 et 25 ans
garnier est très jeune il est beau et ce
qui frappe c'est son regard un regard
que tous les contemporains dépeindront
comme magnétique vibrant il est revêtu
d'un caoutchouc comme on dit à l'époque
c'est-à-dire à l'imperméable un
caoutchouc jaune
la coiffer une casquette et puis à
l'intérieur dans le coupé derrière la
vitre car à cette époque qu'il y à la
place des chauffeurs qui est à l'air
libre est illégal
le coupé il y a un garçon qui
s'appellerait montcalm un très jeune
aussi de petite taille avec un visage
enfantin et puis à binocles cerclées de
fer il porte un pardessus à martingale
et puis sur la tête un chapeau melon à
bord plein donc bruits suspects dans le
capot et bono le chauffeur jules bonnot
est descendu soulève le capot il
s'aperçoit que c'est la poulie
d'entraînement du ventilateur
et justement il y un quincaillier c'est
une chance et il envoie garnier acheter
un boulon de 8 avec son écrou le cahier
livres se boulons et immédiatement bono
fait la réparation visiblement c'est un
homme qui connaît bien les voitures
et puis maintenant la réparation
s'achève raymond qui est à l'intérieur
raymond kalmin est descendu un patient
dison b dépêche toi nous n'avons plus
que quatre minutes mais ça va aller
et voilà la voiture qui repart les trois
hommes sont dans trois ou quatre hommes
à voilà ce qu'on ne sais pas peut-être y
at-il deux hommes dans le coupé raymond
call my peut être un autre
ce quatrième homme on n'a jamais su s'il
était là aussi n'y étaient pas des
témoins jureront qu'ils l'ont vu
d'autres n'ont rien vu et puis on
s'approche
d'un des pots de vin la beaujolaise on
s'arrête
et puis on avance encore un peu raymond
raymond kalmin et ses amis l'appellent
raymond la science et je vous dirai
pourquoi bientôt raymond kalma est
descendu seul sur le trottoir il a
troqué d'ailleurs une casquette à la
place de son chapeau melon il est seul à
l'air très dégagée sur le trottoir et
tout à coup il dit en se penchant vers
les autres qui sont restés dans la
voiture
le voilà est en effet arrive sur le
trottoir un encaisseur vous savez c'est
une époque où on ne se cache pas chacun
avoue très exactement sa qualité c'est
l'époque où les poètes portent des
chapeaux à larges bords et des laval y
est alors les enquêteurs sont à billes
en encaisser horizons en uniforme
d'encaisseur redingote avec boutons
dorés et puis à granby cornes
sinon question de la société générale
en effet la côte et il y à une agence de
la société générale prix ordinaire
octave garnier est descendu à son tour
de la voiture il s'avance à côté de
raymond calme un raymond la science
il s'avance au devant de l'anc et soeurs
qui est escorté d'un garde du corps
l'enquêteur s'appelle cap be le garde du
corps s'appelle paiement et lorsque
garnier est à deux pas de l'enquêteur
tout à coup il sort un revolver de sa
poche et tirs manqués sur saab a
lentement sur le genou alors un deuxième
coup
et cette fois l'an qué soeur est à terre
inanimé avec une grande maîtrise de soi
raymond la science s'est emparé du sac
de toile qui portait à la main et
maintenant il veut tirer la sacoche qui
était accroché à son épaule mais l'homme
mines endormies unanime évanouie tient
la sacoche dans ça m'a crispé il faut
qu'octave garnier écrase avec son talon
cette main pour que l'on puisse prendre
sacoche pieman s'est enfui terrorisé il
a essuyé deux ou trois coups de feu qui
ne l'ont pas atteint
c'est dans la rue la terreur des gens
surgissent des boutiques et les autres
s'éloignent cependant que jules bonnot
qui a en respect les passants qui a
cours à coups de revolver personne n'ait
atteint et les autres remontent dans la
voiture toujours la même maîtrise de soi
au moment où raymond la science monter
dans la voiture peut il a perdu la
sacoche de tomber dans le caniveau
il l'a ramassée très tranquillement il
aimante et maintenant la voiture et par
personne ne les rattrapera et la voiture
roule et la voiture roulait elle ira
d'abord aux boulevards extérieurs
ensuite à saint denis ensuite à pontoise
et c'est seulement après pontoise qu'on
s'arrêtera sur un banc de jma pour faire
l'inventaire de ce qu'on a obtenu à la
faveur de ce hold up le premier hold up
tant en automobile
on s'aperçoit qu'il y a dans le sac et
dans la sacoche 5100 francs en louis
d'or et d'argent
ce qui n'est pas énorme deux mille
francs deux cent mille francs plutôt en
titres nominatifs donc impossible à
négocier et 190 mille francs titres au
porteur ça on verra
et puis on va jusqu'à dieppe le propos
de ces gens est de jeter la voiture dans
la mer malheureusement arrivé à quelques
encablures justement de la mer et bien
la voiture s'arrête mais plus d'essence
c'est seulement les plaques
d'immatriculation que l'on jettera dans
la main et les trois hommes reprennent
le train arriver à paris à une heure du
matin dans la cour de rome un camelot
vend des journaux c'est la patrie et il
crie le titre l'audace incroyable des
bandits en automobile et alors ce que
ressentent jules bonnot raymond la
science
et octave garnier c'est quelque chose
comme de leur gré caby n'est pas ma
langue est seul il survivre à ses
blessures
la société générale annonce déjà qu'elle
donnera une prime de 12 mille cinq cents
francs cette prime ne cessera
d'augmenter dans les semaines qui
suivent à qui donnera des indications
sur les bandits la chasse est ouverte on
le sent bien la chasse que l'on
appellera la chasse aux anarchistes
voilà le mot est prononcé
anarchie c c'est devenu un nom commun
quand on dit c'est l'anarchie bien on
veut dire qu'il ya là de la confusion du
désordre et si vous appelez quelqu'un du
nom d'un anarchiste et vous lui dites
vous êtes un anarchiste est beau c'est
certainement pas parce que vous lui
voulait du bien donc c'est un mot qui a
pris un sens particulier c'est oublier
le sens original du mot ce sens lui a
été donné par des gens qui ont essayé
d'imaginer un système politique et
social cohérent qui exaltait la liberté
de l'individu la liberté individuelle
avant tout dans le cadre d'un état qui
ne serait justement plus un état où il
n'y aurait pas de gouvernement central
l'homme libre l'homme totalement les
alors alors évidemment c'est une idée
qui date des plus anciens temps de
l'humanité mais c'est surtout au 19ème
siècle que l'anarchie a pris sa forme sa
forme définitive
à l'origine il y a eu les utopistes ce
qu'on appelait les utopistes saint-simon
kb fourier et puis ensuite il y a eu
proudhon pro doc qui s'est écrié la
propriété c'est le vol ça c'est la
phrase de base de la marge
et puis ensuite il y a eu le
syndicalisme anarchiste un art show ça
légalisme il y a eu le communisme
anarchiste de bakounine qui ne voulait
pas de dictature du prolétariat et puis
il y a eu des théoriciens il ya eu ce
tir nerfs l'allemand coprod kim le russe
le biologiste français le dantec le
géographe français elisée reclus et puis
bientôt l'otan cette anarchie rester
théorique et puis vers 1880 certains ont
voulu passer à l'action
l'époque de la violence a commencé et on
se souvient bien sûr des années 1892 et
1894 les années sanglantes de l'anarchie
la des anarchistes voulais témoigner
attirer l'attention sur les misères du
monde sur les iniquités du monde et là
il aller jusqu'au bout de leurs
témoignages ravachol lancé c'est bon
vaillant lancer sa bombe au milieu de la
chambre des députés henri au milieu du
café terminus caserio assassiner le
président de la république sadi carnot
et à cette époque déjà dans le sein du
mouvement à l'argile décision
des discussions ardente s'était produit
pour good anarchiste refuser la viole et
ne comprennent pas que d'autres passent
à la violence est d'ailleurs ces
violences condamnées presque
universellement s'est éteinte d'aylmer
un certain nombre de l'anarchiste sont
passés au syndicalisme révolutionnaire
et d'autre tout de même resté fidèle à
l'anarchie dans sa pureté
vers les années 1910 au milieu des
anarchistes on a vu pourtant apparaître
ce qu'on appellera les îles légaliste
face aux autres anarchistes
on appelait les individualise les îles
légaliste vont plus loin ils vont
retourne pas la même violence que les
ravachol et les vaillants mais ils
veulent appliquer à leur profit le
conseil de pro dont la phrase de pros
dont la propriété c'est le vol
ils veulent pratiquer ce qu'ils
appelleront la reprise individuelle
c'est à dire reprendra la société
puisque il n'y a pas de propriété
puisque ce qui est propriété vol il faut
reprendre cette propriété fallacieuse
par le vol justement voilà comment les
îles légaliste vont peu à peu à travers
la france se transformer en voleur pour
reprendre le mot bourgeois mais il y en
a pas d'autre
et là aussi de nouveau des discussions
ardente vont être dans le sein du
mouvement anarchiste car il ya les
autres qui n'accepte pas les îles
légaliste qui trouve que ça n'est pas
tolérable
cela fait du tort à la cause que en même
temps ce n'est pas défendable sur le
plan des principes c'est ce que dira
l'un d'eux un voleur un anarchiste
voleurs en lui disant est ce que tu
crois vraiment qu en volant une
bicyclette
tu va refaire la société et parmi ceux
qui n'acceptent pas il y a deux
personnes qui s'appelle victor qu'il
bakchich et sa compagne rire est maître
jean
en 1905 et tenait un journal le journal
l'anarchie celui qu'il avait fondé et
est incertain libertad c'était tout au
moins son pseudonyme un personnage
étrange 1 affirme avec des jambes
atrophiées tenus par des îles se
soutenait par des béquilles et dans les
bagarres où ils se lançaient les
béquilles devenait de terribles gourdins
et libertad surtout était un orateur
étant libertad parler des hommes de
l'avenir du genre humain de l'anarchie
qui ferait naître le bonheur des hommes
n'est bien libertad soulevé la passion
l'enthousiasmé motion et puis libertad
était mort à 33 ans à la suite d'une
bagarre des coûts nous ont dit ses amis
qu'il avait reçues des policiers
celui qui lui a succédé à la direction
de l'anarchie c'est un autre à l'artiste
un certain lors hulot alors l'ariane
pareil personnage médiocre pas très
intelligent personnage
disons le carrément suspect et qui
n'avaient surtout que la conscience de
son propre génie et en même temps une
paresse total il dans cette espèce de
phalanstère de romainville où vivent et
les anarchistes et bien leur hulot lui
alors que tout ce travail et leur hulot
se mettait dans un arbre s'est elle
était tout nu pour recevoir les rayons
du soleil et regarder les autres travail
est peut-être pas une façon par ailleurs
leur hulot emprunter les femmes de ses
camarades en fawcett est un personnage
sent atterré et surtout une grande
incapacité et on a vite senti autour de
lui qu'il allait conduire le journal
l'anarchie à sa perte
alors certains ont aussi suggéré que
l'on prenne victor qu'il bat chiche
comme non pas directeur n'y a pas de
directeur chez les anarchy mais comme
animateur
de la revue et c'est alors que rire est
maître jean qui depuis quelques temps
était la compagne de kiel bakchich
alors que rire est maître jean lui a dit
non elle ne vous voyait là vous voyez
non n'acceptez pas vous allez avoir tous
les ennuis du monde avec les îles
légaliste
pourquoi ne pas essayer at il répondu
et il a essayé oui il a 20 ans elle a 22
ans et c'est un couple charmant lui
c'est un russe comme son nom l'indiqué
son père est un exilé il a dû quitter la
russie s'enfuir de russie parce qu'il
était opposant son grand oncle a été
pendu également parce qu'il était
opposant une sorte de tradition de
révolution chez les kills bakchich il a
grandi victor à bruxelles et il a
découvert pendant son adolescence
kropotkine et l'anarchie alors il a
milité parmi les anarchistes belge et
puis ensuite il est revenu à paris et
c'est là qu'il s'est agrégée au
mouvement de romainville et c'est là
maintenant qu'on le propose comme
animateur de la revue et c'est là qu'il
accepte rire est elle est bien rire est
malgré son jeune âge a déjà été mariée
elle était mariée avec un anarchiste
bien sûr un certain maître jean et à
kehl a donné deux enfants
ce maître jean était un ouvrier scellier
converti à l'anarchie et qui lui aussi
voulait la reprise individuelle qui donc
avait décidé de fabriquer de la fausse
monnaie
cela lui demandait beaucoup de mal cela
le coûter très cher il gagnait dans les
meilleures semaines 30 francs alors
qu'autrefois de son métier d'ouvrier
scellier le gagner 10 francs par jour
c'était mal à peine de changer
alors évidemment personnage son
envergure petits personnages et rire est
femme intelligence femme intelligente
s'est éloigné de lui assez vite et quand
elle a rencontré viktor qu'il match avec
le rayonnement qui émanait de ce garçon
est bien ça a été le coup de foudre
elle est venue s'installer avec lui et
ils ont su comme c'était à prévoir des
ennuis avec les légalistes à ce point
que ne s'entendent en plus du tout
ils ont quitté romainville ont installé
le siège de l'anarchie rue fessart à
belleville et c'est l'âme qu'ils
habitaient désormais et c'est là le 21
décembre 1911 que justement victor qu'il
bakchich chérir est maître jean était en
train de lire les journaux parce qu'il
était extrêmement attentif à la sphère
de la rue ordener il y avait des témoins
que les journalistes avaient
interviewées qui décrivait les bandits
et malheureusement rirait et victor
n'est reconnaissait d'après leur
signalement très bien ces bandits et
c'était leurs amis alors ils ont attendu
et quelques jours plus tard ils ont vu
surgir rue fait ça octave garnier et
raymond la science
alors c'était vous a dit qu'il battu
bien sûr que c'était hors qu'il bat
chiche qui réprouv ait de tels actes
les réprouvés d'autant plus que raymond
la science vraiment calme hein c'était
son plus vieil ami sont plus anciennes
amies ils s'étaient rencontrés à ixelles
près de bruxelles un jour alors qu'il
était lui petit garçon était habillé à
la russe avec une blouse russe avec des
carreaux de couleur différente
alors le petit bruxellois le petit hic
ces lois qui était vraiment calme un
fils d'un français eysines et d'ailleurs
qui voyait passer ce personnage bariolés
s'est mis à rigoler et immédiatement
après le russe lui a posé son panier de
provisions par terre et servait sur
vraiment ils se sont bagarrés
et c'est de là qu'est née leur amitié et
puis ils ont grandi ensemble ont
découvert ensemble histoire de la
révolution française de louis blanc avec
des illustrations vous voyez les
parisiens avec des pics qui descendait
dans la rue et les deux gosses se
disaient nous aussi on ira dans la rue
raymond la science c'était pourquoi là
silencieux nous nous le serons dans un
instant raymond calme un raymond kalla
et et fils d'un cordonnier alcoolique
qui le battait il n'y avait aucune
tendresse à la maison et puis à 13 ans
l'avait mis au travail
je travaillais 16h par vous savez ce pas
une époque tendre pas du tout
ces heures par jour et puis leur
victoire lui qui avaient appris qu'ils
avaient fait des études qu'ils savaient
des choses il n'en était pas jaloux
raymond mais il était triste parce qu'il
aurait voulu savoir aussi des choses
alors mais comment apprend puisqu'il
travaille 16 heures par jour dans son
épicerie
alors ils s'arrêtent de travailler et
pour gagner du temps pour pouvoir aller
dans les bibliothèques qui se met à
voler il est pris bien sûr il ya 17 ans
il fait sa première prison mais en
sortant de prison
retourne à la bibliothèque royale à
bruxelles il prend auguste comte il
prend pas des auteurs facile trop guest
compte le lit et découvre quelque chose
d'inouï à ses yeux la science le 19e
siècle c'est la science on y croit on
remplace pour un peu dieu par la science
c'est l'avenir de la science la science
c'est l'avenir
et voilà que raymond kalman maintenant
ne jure plus que par la science là le
mot science sans arrêt à la bouche alors
on l'appellera raymond la science
il partira voyagera en suisse reviendra
en france suire à l'époque l'âge du
service militaire reviendra en belgique
militera avec les anarchistes parce que
en même temps que victor qu'il bat
gilles a découvert compote kiné il est à
l'artiste et continue à voler mais il
est anarchiste il est donc un archi
style légaliste déjà et puis un beau
jour il décide de repartir pour la
france il va retrouver qu'il bat chiche
chez les anarchistes de romainville l'un
des hommes donc ils bakchich a reconnu
le signalement s'appelle jules bonnot
c'est notre boulot à nous et bono lui
qui s est bien bono lui est né dans le
doubs ce près de montbéliard
à 5 ans il perd sa mère comme pour
raymond la science pas de tendresse à la
maison alors il a les taloches du père
qui est un ouvrier soudeur
alors il est révolté contre son père
après il ya la discipline de l'école il
est révolté contre l'école après il a
les patrons il révolté contre les
patrons et puis il se met dans tous les
mauvais coups chaque fois kien dre ville
est au nombre des meneurs comme on dit
alors bertoia puis dans bausch pour lui
et les révoltés contre la société
et puis voilà qu'arrive l'époque de il
est également soupçonné de vol c'est pas
sûr qu'ils les écoles
vous savez on ne prête qu'aux riches
alors là aussi les condamner une un
casier judiciaire puis fait son service
militaire et chose curieuse il est un
bon soldat
là il n'est pas révolté il devient même
champion de tir champion de tir du
régiment et puis pendant qu'ils les
soldats il y à des manoeuvres et pendant
qu'il est aux manoeuvres et bien il
arrive un jour dans une maison et dans
cette maison il ya une femme qui élève
sa fille les charmantes la fille et il
aime et la demande en mariage et après
le service militaire il les pose alors
un départ si tout va bien son âge dans
le bonheur y aura d'ailleurs un enfant
qui viendra et puis malheureusement une
fois de plus il se lance dans une grève
le lendemain au chômage il faut aller en
suisse
il trouve un nouveau métier grève il
s'il en chômage
il arrive à lyon devient mécanicien
automobile il ya maintenant trente mille
voitures à travers la france il faut les
spécialistes devient un très bon
spécialiste des voitures
il passe son permis demandés mais tous
ces métiers changent sans cesse mais ces
métiers qui change eh bien ça n'est pas
pour resserrer les liens entre sa femme
et lui elle est la soif de stabilité et
puis elle souvent on a faim à la maison
là rien alors un jour le secrétaire du
syndicat lui dit vous savez votre mari
il a soi-disant des idées politiques
mais en fait c'est parce qu'il est un
révolté c'est sont ses instincts qu'il
dissimule à travers des idées elle est
convaincue elle tombe dans les bras du
secrétaire du syndicat lancera sa
maîtresse et un beau jour bono rentrera
au mauvais moment
il y aura bagarrer bonora le dessous
c'est à partir du ce moment là que bono
croira - au syndicalisme et voilà la
femme est partie il est seul
et la révolte est plus forte et plus
grande que jamais et partir de ce moment
là ne voudra plus travailler c'est fini
maintenant ce qu'il fera vivre ce sont
des cambriolages alors il volera des
motos il volera des autos à tous avec un
certain platanes ou en italien
et ils ont fait un véritable commerce
exporte le voitures volées en suisse et
maintenant tout se passe bien en même
temps avec platano il les met au point
un système de vol de vol à l'automobile
il arrive avec l'automobile devant un
notaire et ça fait bien parce que vous
savez lire même trente mille voitures à
travers toute la france avait pas
beaucoup de voitures au kilomètre carré
alors le notaire qui voit deux clients
descendre d'une voiture il est très bien
impressionné alors on mentionne notaire
on est reçu on parle d'une société
imaginaire qu'on veut mettre sur pied
alors le notaire prend des notes et puis
finalement
et bien finalement on appris pendant ce
temps là le plan de l'appartement et
l'emplacement du coffre et on y
reviendra deux ou trois nuits plus tard
et au chalumeau ou n'ouvrira le coffre
et on gagne bien sa vie
un seul coup dans che dans une seule
étude de notaire apportera trente six
mille francs de l'époque
vous savez c'est d'une somme trente six
mille francs un employé du ministère
gagne à cette époque à 200 francs par
mois il habite maintenant chez une
certaine madame tall ont enfin chez un
ménage taux longs taux longs qui est
gardien la cimetière et taux longs boit
énormément ils voient plusieurs absences
tous les soirs deux sortes qui s'endort
comme une masse jusqu'au matin comme
madame tall on est une femme
mon dieu qui
bien certain plaisir et bien elle
préfère les trouver auprès de bono
qu'auprès de son mari endormi et c'est
ainsi qu'elle rejoint tous les soirs
dans son lit bono et voilà que bono
tombe amoureux bono aimera judith de
long et même il
ils rêvent ils rêvent d'un très grand
coup gagnerait beaucoup l'argent et l'or
il partirait tous les deux ils n'en
lèvres elle partirait pour l'angleterre
où ils vivraient dans un cottage
voilà le rêve de bonnery du fait même
donner des leçons d'anglais puis un beau
jour platanes aux arrêts la police et
celle des titres comprend j'ai vu la
police de lons un génie j'ai pas pu
entrer je suis venu tout de suite ils
vont venir chez toi bon il faut s'en
fait et c'est un déchirement pour
bonnaud parce qu'il va s'arracher
s'arrachait des braves de judith taux
longs et pourtant il faut bien partir on
part en voiture et platano a sur lui un
petit héritage qu'il a fait en italie 30
mille francs est en route et en route
platane aude racontera bono platano se
tirera involontairement une balle de
revolver dans la tête il sera grièvement
blessé et comme il se débat comme il
hurle et bien lui bono sera obligé de
lâcher mais ça c'est la version bono de
toute façon il a récupéré des trente
mille francs et platano est mort la
police te croira pas du tout à cette
version la poly croira que tout
simplement bono a assassiné son
compagnon ce qui n'est pas exclu
il arrive à paris avec un but se
mêlaient aux milieux anarchistes ou il
recrutera chez les îles légaliste des
complices pour les grands coups qu'il
médite alors bono est ce qu'il est
anarchiste non il a fréquenté quelques
anaxis il n'est pas à l'archi bolo c'est
un hors la loi pour lui l'anarchie n'est
pas une idée comme pour raymond la
science c'est un moyen alors pour le
moment il se cache
après la sphère de la rue ordener parce
que la sphère de la rue ordener c'est
bono qui l'a proposé il est allé à la
librairie de l'idée libre là il a
rencontré raymond la science ils ont lié
connaissance et pis raymond la science
n'a introduite dans son petit milieu des
légalistes et bono a tout de suite parlé
des choses a fait d'abord l'automobile
ensuite être armés disons-nous bien que
tous ces illégalistes si ce sont des
cambrioleurs des voleurs ne sont pas des
assassins c'est bono qui va faire deux
messieurs et on se procure au début de
décembre une voiture à boulogne on l'a
vol dans mon la vole dans le garage d'un
hôtel particulier à boulogne le garage
de monsieur normand et on part en part
et
bolo c'est maintenant qu'il a à faire il
connaît bien
toute cette petite bande qui pourra
ensemble ou séparément ou
alternativement le seconde est d'abord
octave grenier octave grenier qui lui
aussi est passé en belgique autrefois et
c'est en belgique qu'il a connu sa
maîtresse celle qu'on appelle marie la
belge qui l'a enlevée qui l'a enlevée à
un mari octave grenier qui lui est une
sorte de forcenés octave grenier qui est
prêt à tout mais qui attendait au fond
pour donner sa mesure que quelqu'un
vienne le provoquer et le provocateur ce
sera bono
donc après grenier la petite bande
comprend aussi karoui karoui quête unsa
belge encore tous ces gens se sont
connus en belgique se sont retrouvés à
paris qui est une sorte d recul avec
malheureusement une toute petite
cervelle tout petit et puis également un
autre qui s'appelle vale vale qui est un
poète vallée qui connaît des centaines
et des milliers de vers qui connaît
toute la poésie qui peut résister
pendant des heures des verts et tous ces
français de belgique ces anarchistes
français de belgique sauf car oui louis
qui est belle des autres français sont
venus à paris se réunir autour du
journal l'anarchie ils ont retrouvé là
d'autres gens d'autres anarchiste par
exemple dieudonné dieudonné un menuisier
nancy qui vient de temps en temps à
paris qui est venu avec sa femme à paris
et laure hulot lui a pris sa femme
alors il est parti très malheureux et
puis également incertain monnier 10 et
menchov et puis encore un nommé sous 10
ou dit un garçon qui n'a pas 20 ans qui
a 13 ans a été créé
de travail en osant même écrasée de
travailler à 13 ans était dubé reculent
eux et depuis il est allé parce qu'il a
fait lui aussi des vols est allé de
prison en hôpital et soudi avoué un
véritable une véritable adoration à rire
est maître jean et qu'il bakchich ils
promènent leur enfance qui d'ailleurs un
peu curieux pour un tuberculeux alors
oui bono maintenant connaît tout c'est
devant ce qu'il pourra faire appel aux
uns et aux autres et déjà il vole cette
voiture et cette voiture on l'a conduit
chez un certain dead velez à bobigny un
camarade anarchiste qui ne demandent
rien les anarchistes ne demande jamais
quoi que ce soit est ce que tu peux
garder la voiture oui je la dame et le
vin au soir on vient la chercher ce
qu'il vienne la chercher ce sont beaux
nos raymond la science et octave grenier
est peut-être un quatrième le but de
l'expédition s'est elle attaque d'un
bijoutier et le temps était mauvais on
sentait qu'il allait pleuvoir et cette
pluie devait faciliter les opérations
parce que le bruit de la pluie aurait
étouffé les bruits de l'attaqué de la
bijouterie et en même temps éloignés les
passants et puis on a attendu la plus
belle épreuve n'a pas plu du tout de
l'année or au matin on était prêt à
rentrer raymond la science disent eh
bien voilà on commencera à nos jours
comment ni bonne puisqu'on est dehors il
faut aller jusqu'au bout s'est offert un
coup bas coût un coup un coût qui n'est
pas préparée mais s'y préparent et j'en
ai préparé alors est en effet depuis
quelques jours il a étudié le
comportement de cet enquêteur de la
société générale qui venait tous les
jours du siège central apporter de
l'argent frais à la succursale de la rue
ardennes et ensuite ils ont fait le coup
la rue ordener vous le connaissez nous
le connaissons après le coup
garnier parti pour amsterdam avec les
titres pour essayer de négocier il n'a
pas eu beaucoup de succès il est revenue
et depuis ils se cachent ils se terrent
et quand raymond la science et octave
garnier viennent chez yvette et chez
victor ils sont visiblement à bout ils
ne pensaient pas que leur affaire frais
tant de bruit qu'on l'ait rechercherait
avec temps d'activité et quand ils s'en
vont après avoir passé la 2 ou 3 heures
avoir bu du café et du thé ce qui est
tout à fait exceptionnelle pour eux
songez qu'un garçon comme raymond la
science à 22 ans n'avait jamais vu de
café jamais vu de tes je vais fumée de
tabac qu'ils étaient chaste végétarien
alors quand ils sont partis rire est et
victor se sont gardées on dit n'iront
pas loin
c'était compter sans bono et bono tu
tenais toujours à ce qu'on aille loin
alors
ils sont repartis pour la belgique ont
fait un coup en belgique ont volé une
voiture à dans son parti pour amsterdam
toujours pour les petites raisons vendu
la voiture pour 8000 francs sont revenus
à gand à gants ils ont essayé de voler
une deuxième voiture ils ont assommé un
chauffeur tiré sur un agent
tout ça ne l'avait pas très bien marché
et puis de retour à paris bono a décidé
de faire un coup à pontoise à pontoise
chez un notaire
suivant ce qui lui avait si bien réussi
à lyon alors on vole une nouvelle
voiture on l'a vol à s'amender et puis
maintenant on traverse parier au volant
des voitures blood ce sens hors de lui
il est heureux il tient le volant ils
roulent ils traversent paris à tout à
l'heure
le voit la rue du havre en face de la
gare saint lazare il n'ya là refusent
avec un agent est-ce qu'il va tourner
lui bono autour du refuge dans le pot
question et il passe tout droit l'agent
l'appel lui dit vous voulez vous arrêter
et l'injure et la jambe et
malheureusement pour lui un camion passe
il est obligé de s'arrêter
malheureusement pour lui malheureusement
pour l'argent parce que les gens
arrivent et l'agent s'appelle garnier
mais où il lui aussi il dit alors quoi
on a juré les agents de la force
publique
vos papiers les voilà les papiers dit
garnier l'autre était en pleine poitrine
là j'entends y les mains et la voiture
part on essaye de la poursuivre une
voiture privée avec un autre agent la
poursuit et elle écrase un passant alors
elle s'arrête et quant à la voiture de
bono et des autres on ne la reverra pas
le coup de pontoise rate
parce qu'au moment où nationaux terriens
passant donne l'alerté il faut partir et
le notaire est prévenue tirs sur les
attaquants et il faut s'en allait c'est
depuis la sphère de la rue du havre que
monsieur lépine
le préfet de police se fera à 6 chez
circulaire dans tous les commissariats
de police au cas où une voiture
automobile refuserait d'obtempérer aux
ordres d'un agent la force publique
celui ci est autorisé à en crever les
pneus avec son sabre c'est le style de
l'époque et c'est la pensée de l'époque
et maintenant havre l affaire de la rue
du havre après la sphère de la rue
ordener les journaux sont plaints des
bandits en automobile on a bien compris
que c'étaient les mêmes à nouveau style
est né jusqu'où iront ils pas ces
bandits en l'automobile et entre temps
entre temps à bobigny et bien des
informations sont arrivés et jusqu'à la
mairie le l'appariteur de la mairie qui
est en même temps correspondant du petit
parisien apprend que chez dette weiler
au garage de bel air on a garé une
delaunay belleville justement pendant
l'époque qui a précédé la sphère de la
rue ordener et l'appariteur va avertir
en même temps la police et son journal
laissez le journal qui râle plus vite
journal qui viendra interviewé cette
valeur qui dit oui on m'apporte une
voiture je le gardais j'ai même fait une
petite réparation dessus et puis après
j'aurais rendu le soir du 20 et j'ai
demandé 15 francs - ont donné 25 c'est
tout mais monsieur joint qui résoud
directeur de la sûreté ne l'entend pas
de cette oreille et va faire arrêter
d'être weiler et la cuisine évidemment
des valeurs ne manquera pas le morceau
contredire mais qui abordait la voiture
vous les connaissez
non pas du tout vous la connaissez non
que les connaît pas et on va tendre une
souricière chez des délais et chez des
devait leur viendra se fait reprendre la
maîtresse de carouge et par la maîtresse
de karoui ans n'ira car oui qu'on ne
pourra pas arrêter mais on saura qu'il
existe et désormais il ya un nom sur les
papiers de la police un nom d'un des
bandits c'est car oui et on n'a pas tort
maintenant paulo voudrais faire un grand
coup dans le midi de la france
monier a tout préparé pour cela il faut
une voiture mais maintenant c'est très
difficile de voler une voiture parce que
après les vols de voitures précédent à
bien tous les garages sont sont fermées
sont claquemurés avec des dispositifs
d'alarmé
une idée pourquoi ne pas raisonner une
voiture sur la route de meules et toute
la bande presque entièrement puisqu'il y
à la bono garnier raymond la science
vonier vallée et sous des sous 10 toute
la bande va jusqu'à mangeront sur la
route de meules à pied en marchant toute
l'année et là on l'attend ces lots et
voilà une voiture c'est une de dion
bouton magnifique tout neuf qui est
livrée à son propriétaire qui est au cap
ferrat qui doit traverser toute la
france il ya là un chauffeur au volant
et le secrétaire du propriétaire
l'homme du cap ferrat qui est à côté du
chauffe et monier s'avancer fait un
signe avec son mouchoir la voiture
s'arrêter les gens demandent qu'est-ce
qui se passe qu'arrive-t-il c'est à ce
moment là que calme
raymond la science et octave garnier se
précipitent revolver au poing ils
comprennent le chauffeur et le
secrétaire ce qui leur arrive
lever les mains en l'air hélas le
chauffeur un geste malheureux au lieu de
lever les mains en l'air
il n'est pas sous le tableau de bord
comme s'il allait prendre une arme à ce
moment là on tique et les deux hommes
s'écroule a battu on le transportera sur
le bord de la route
on montera dans la voiture toute la
bande se serrera dans la voiture et deux
heures plus tard on arrive à chantilly
on arrive à chantilly
pour attaquer la banque pour attaquer la
société générale décidément la société
générale n'a pas beaucoup de chance et
c'est là en pleine matinée alors que la
place grouille de monde que les bandits
arrêtent leur voiture garnier saute à
tête suivi de raymond la science
bono reste volant les bandits rentrer
dans la bande font feu aussitôt deux
employés tombe foudroyé il remplit sa à
vrsac d'or d'argent de billets de banque
en tout pour cinquante mille francs
et puis ils se replient la foule est
tenu en respect tout autour terrorisée
par bono qu'à son volant qui tient
brandi vers la foule son revolver et
parks ou dit le jeune sous 10 le
physique qui m carabine on l'appellera
l'homme à la carabine et qui tient la
foule et qui crie
kalt et calt et où je vous canardent et
maintenant les voilà qu'ils partent
les voilà qui partent qui roule la
voiture s'en va et c'est l'illustration
qui donnera ce document saisissant c'est
à dire le gendarme
le gendarme de luzarches le seul qui ait
voulu intervenir et comment est-il le
gendarme de luzarches il est à cheval
est alors courageusement le pauvre homme
il est sur son cheval et galope et
galope derrière la voiture et
dérisoirement l'image du gendarme à
cheval s'inscrit sur la caisse lui lente
de la voiture
alors de nouveau c'est le scandale
le scandale immense les bandits en
automobiles ont récidivé ils ont fait
leur coup le plus incroyable
il y a encore mort d'homme mais enfin
ils ont osé s'en prendre à une banque en
plein jour on les a laissés faire si son
parti sont ademe
est-ce que ça va durer est ce que ça ne
va pas durer et alors toute la france
occupe des bandits de ce qu'on appelle
la bande à bonnot parce que maintenant
ça y est ils sont dénoncés
on connaît leurs noms à la police il y a
eu vous savez une foule d'indicateurs
la police a reçu des centaines de
lettres des dénonciations de toutes
sortes
anonyme presque tout donné mais la
police a suivi toutes les pistes qui se
sont présentés air et c'est ainsi que la
police a arrêté successivement dieudonné
pourquoi dieudonné bien parce que on
était arrivé à lui et que on avait pu
l'arrêter il se cacher avec sa femme qui
était revenu à lui d'ailleurs
alors on l'avait arrêté et puis on
l'avait présenté acabit tout à fait
remis maintenant et camille avait dit
c'est lui c'est lui qui a tiré sur moi
mais ça ne savons bien que c'était faux
voilà le témoignage humain alors il est
en prison aux yeux le nez et puis
ensuite on arrêtait monnier et puis par
monnier on est arrivé à un autre un
certain gauzy parce que vous n'y avait
sur lui une lettre qui s'adressait à
cuzin gauzy alors on a décidé d'aller
voir chez gosis était dans une dans un
quartier
who goes y tenait un magasin de soldes
alors on est allé voir jusque là entre
temps on avait arrêté sous dit oui parce
que les journaux avaient reproduit cette
fameuse phrase
kalt et calt et aux bien je vous
canarder un indicateur en ces
indicateurs tellement bénévoles y avait
la prime aussi maintenant la prime
s'élevait à plus de cent mille francs un
indicateur avait dit ça c'est le langage
dessous dit si vous voulez retrouver
sous d'y aller à berck pas ce qu'il a
dit que quand il aurait de l'argent il
est reste soigné à berck on va à berck
on retrouve six ou dix on l'arrête
alors maintenant on va chez gossip et
c'est monsieur juin le patron le sous
directeur de la sûreté qui est là avec
deux inspecteurs on interroge le guen en
question qui ne sait rien vous avez
quelqu'un chez vous personne même pas ma
femme et mes enfants sont partis sont en
vacances bien et qu est-ce qui a au 1er
étage mon appartement particulier à
personne on va aller voir des joueurs et
au monde
on passe dans une première pièce c puis
dans une seconde qui est plongée dans
l'obscurité les volets sont fermés mais
dans la pénombre jouer aperçoit une
forme un homme trapu ramassé sur
lui-même par les quelques rayons de
lumière qui passe à travers les
persiennes il le reconnaît dit mais
c'est blanc et à ce moment-là bonotti et
joue un s'écroule frappé d'une balle en
pleine tête
et puis bon lotir sur l'inspecteur
colmar qui est blessé bibelots tout à
coup ces fonds l'inspecteur robert qui
est tout seul était pouvant tc10 me
situer lui-même alors il n'emmène colmar
pour le soigner et à peine at il quitté
la pièce que bono saute sur ses jambes
car il avait contre fait le mort et
alors là il court dans l'appartement
voisin se fait ouvrir la porte par la
voisine dit si tu parles je te
descendent cours à la fenêtre il ya cinq
ou six mètres a sauté tant pis le
soutien toits de cabanes qui est mort
six kg amorti sa chute il s'enfuit on
l'enverra ben alors là le scandale est
immense vous pensez juin l'un des
premiers policiers de paris un homme
mort à 40 ans les obsèques qui lui sont
faites sont grandioses et on se dit
qu'il faut absolument trouver
bono et c'est une dénonciation encore
une d'un pharmacien d'un pharmacien qui
dira avoir soigné un homme blessé aux
mains oui c'était beau lot dans sa chute
et qui ressemblait à bono tels que les
journaux avaient publié sa photographie
alors en cours parce que dans l'endroit
où exercent ce pharmacien il ya ce qu'on
appelle le nid rouge c'est à dire un
groupe de pavillons élevé par un
millionnaire anarchiste ça existe un
certain fromentin et alors il a élevé
ses pavillons pour que les camarades
puissent y habiter il les appelle là
s'appelle louise michel l'autre elisée
reclus et là cette fois c'est monsieur
richard le chef de la sûreté lui même
qui se présentent au nid rouges et on
décide de commencer par explorer le
pavillon d'un certain dubois dubois est
un garagiste il était en train de
réparer une voiture on crie pallice
alors à ce moment-là dubois fou de rage
saisi un revolver qui est sur le siège
de la voiture qu'il réparait cris
assassins et tirent sur les policiers
l'un d'eux est atteint un autre policier
tire sur du bois qui ces fonds il va et
on se met en devoir de gravir l'escalier
extérieur pour monter au premier étage
et là tout à coup on voit apparaître sur
le seuil ballon qui tirent et la specter
qui était en train de monter est atteint
et là bas les volo serov repli à
l'intérieur et la police se replie aussi
d'ailleurs parce que monsieur dit
charles veut pas que ses policiers soit
disant trop grand danger
et alors car nous sommes à huit heures
du matin quand tout cela commençait
alors ce qui va se passer c'est quelque
chose à la fois de tragique et de
grotesque
parce que pour prendre un seul homme on
va mettre en jeu des forces
considérables
on mobilise toute la gendarmerie de
choisy-le-roi en mobilise et mobilise
les citoyens de choisir et on leur
demande de venir avec leurs fusils vous
imaginez et les gens sont si heureux de
chasser l'homme même si cet homme est un
bandit et ils viennent et viennent avec
leurs fusils carabines leurs fusils de
chasse et tout ce monde
sam lutine autour de la maison
il y aura un certain moment quatre à
cinq mille personnes 4 à 5000 curieux
autour de la maison où bono est assiégé
et là on n'est pas prêt se sentir enclin
pl dire
alors que faire on tire on tire on tire
on la façade est criblé de balles
ça ne donne rien alors on une idée on va
déposer des charges de dynamite on va
faire sauter la maison est à l'abri de
voitures de paille quelqu'un s'avance à
l'officier s'avance dépose une première
charge de dynamite qui fait long feu
seconde charge de dynamite qui ne fait
qu'une brèche
il faut une troisième charges de
dynamite pour que la maison alors tout à
coup explose littéralement et commence à
brûler alors là c'est l'assaut vous
pénètre au rez-de-chaussée on retrouve
le cadavre de dubois l'entourer de
flamands le tir des flammes
on monte au premier et là c'est guichard
qui entre avec ses inspecteurs dans la
pièce où se tapit bono le trouve enroulé
dans un matelas pour éviter justement
d'être canarder de partout et grièvement
blessé il a essayé de se donner la main
il n'y est pas parvenu il est encore
vivant il a encore un revolver à la main
et ils crient aux policiers qui entre
tatsa l'eau et étaient étirées alors là
il est criblé de balles et on emmènera
on emmènera bonhomme on emmènera
moribonde la foule voudra naturellement
le lyncher la foule et on le protègera
de la foule et c'est en arrivant à
l'hôtel dieu qu'il mourra maintenant ne
reste plus de libre de toute la bande à
bonnot que garnier et vallées bolo avait
laissé près de lui son testament qu'il
avait écrit pendant le siège est dans ce
testament il l'écrivait dieudonné est
innocent garnier lui avait écrit au
matin il avait eu l'audace d'écrire au
journal le matin une lettre qu'ils
étaient publiés en disant c'est moi
l'homme de la rue ordener dieudonné n'y
est pour rien à dieudonné est innocent
et maintenant garnier vallée se cache
dans une petit pavillon de nogent sur ma
garnier avec lui sa maîtresse marie la
belge et un soir tout à coup
dénoncé par un voisin 20 voisin qui n'a
peut-être aperçu qu'il y avait là deux
hommes qui ne sortait pas et une femme
qui allait faire les commissions il
avait dit attention ça pourrait être des
gens de la bande à bonnot on est venu et
maintenant la police et la police crime
sur bichat rendez vous les hommes se
replie à l'intérieur du pavillon
répondent par les coups de feu la
fusillade crépiter pis s'arrête et à ce
moment là on voit sortir en courant mari
les deux hommes l'ont obligé l'ont
expulsée du pavillon ils ne veulent pas
qu'elle meure avec eux et on fera le
siège pendant toute la nuit
la foule arrive elle aussi pendant toute
la soirée
elle vient par train elle vient par
voiture elle vient en vélo
elle vient en tramway on est obligé de
dédoubler les tramways pour conduire les
gens pour assister à ce spectacle
il faudra deux compagnies de zouaves
pour contenir la foule
et alors là aussi on utilise tout
mitrailleuse l'eau charge de mes limites
en fait également sauter la maison et on
donne l'assaut quand on pénétrera dans
la pièce on trouvera garnier et valais
l'un mort l'autre moribond qui lèvera
son revolver pour tirer qui tiraille qui
sera lui aussi criblé de balles il ne
restera plus à la morgue que deux
cadavres de ces jeunes gens qui ont
choisi l'illégalisme qui ont choisi
l'assassinât qui ont choisi de trahir
leurs frères anarchiste
alors maintenant c'est fini il n'y a
plus de bande à bonnot il n'ya plus qu'à
les juges etc a jugé ce qu'on a pris ils
sont là 20 sur les bancs de la cour
d'assises le 3 février 1913 et les
vedettes se sont qu'il baci chérir est
maître jean et oui on les a arrêtés
parce que pour l'accusation la tête 7e
ce qui est dérisoire et stupide puisque
était contre tout ça alors on les
arrêter et les vedettes se sont raymond
la science rénovation ce qui pérorent
qui parle qui plaisante qui dialogue
avec le président et dans ses dialogues
ce n'est pas le président qui a le
dessus vedette recettes encore dieu
donniez dieudonné qui jure qu'il est
innocent et calmant raymond la science
dira là dans le box des accusés
je jure qu'il n'était pas là il est
innocent voilà donc tous les complices
qui innocentent dieudonné et pourtant il
est inculpé
et pourtant il est là sur les bancs
épiler aussi car oui et son associé
metge qui sont eux inculpés d'un
horrible assassinat à thiais ils ont une
nuit assassiné un octogénaire et sa
vieille servante pour les voler ces
sauvages c'est indéfendable c'est
affreux et puis il ya les autres ça dure
quatre semaines et le jury revient avec
un verdict incohérent car oui et metge
les assassins affreuse pied ont des
circonstances atténuantes il échappe à
la mort mais dieudonné innocenté par
tous les autres dieudonné dont on n'a
rien prouvé en fait qu'une mobilité de
données qu'on a la main sont condamnés à
mort également raymond la science bien
sûr monnier et sous 10
qu'il bat chiche rire est elle rire été
acquitté il bat chiche condamné à quatre
ans de prison le 21 avril 1913 le chat
fou est dressé dieudonné a été gracié
parce que tout de même c'était tellement
exorbitant cette condamnation
il n'en fera pas moins 20 ans de bagne
il sera libéré à la suite d'une
courageuse campagne d'albert longue car
oui lui une demi heure après l'audience
la dernière audience est empoisonnée ou
at il trouvé le poison ne s'est pas il
est mort et maintenant vont monter à
l'échafaud les les trois derniers
monsieur deibler le bourreau a décidé de
les faire mourir par an d'âge le plus
jeune d'abba alors c'est sous 10 qui
marche le premier il tremble et dit oui
je tremble mais c'est de froid comme
bailly pendant la révolution sa tête en
amont la science qui monte sur
l'échafaud qui regardent la pole à perte
de vue des gens sont venus de partout
attente depuis la veille au soir
d'autres sont venues des boîtes de nuit
ont festoyé entend tenue de soirée il y
a des
grande cocotte les courtisanes il y a
des gens du monde il y à toutes sortes
de gens et raymond la science le relance
c'est beau hein l'agonie d'un homme et
sa tête temps
et puis voilà monnier qui dit tout
simplement
adieu à vous monsieur oui à la société
où est sa tête c'est fini la bande à
bonnot
et celle qui peut-être prononcera l'acte
de pisa sion le plus dur ce n'est pas le
procureur sait rire est maître gens qui
dans ses souvenirs a dit toute la
répugnance toute l'horreur le mépris que
si tu es en elle ces actes indéfendable
il y à des théories et puis à des gens
qui ne comprennent mal et des gens qui
dévie tout en se déployant et c'est
bernard thomas l'un des meilleurs
historiens de la faire avec georges adam
bernard thomas qui a pu dire que depuis
66 ans le drapeau noir porte le deuil
des crimes de jules bonnot
[Musique]